hello everyone my name is kelly robbins
i'm an assistant professor in the
section of plant breeding and genetics
at cornell university and today i'm
going to be presenting some of the work
that we've been doing in the breeding
informatics area of inquiry is part of
the innovation lab for crop improvement
before i get started i would like to
take a moment to thank the organizers of
napb 2021 as well as stephen krusevich
for giving me the opportunity to present
here today
to start i'd like to thank the amazing
team of people that i get to work with
on a daily basis
within the breeding informatics team we
have uh mallet who is a postdoc in the
robin's lab a quantitative geneticist
who does a lot of work on this project
focusing on breeding scheme optimization
francisco and sam are both amazing
developers that are working on putting
together a lot of the enabling
capabilities that we're delivering as
part of the breeding informatics area of
inquiry we also have several clever
collaborators outside of the project we
work closely with excellence in breeding
the broppy project as well as the
integrated breeding platform to deploy
bms to our partners
here we have a diagram that i pulled off
of the ilc web page
just to give an idea of where the
breeding informatics
area of inquiry fits within the broader
landscape of the innovation lab for crop
improvement so with breeding informatics
we're really primarily tasked with
building the types of enabling
capabilities that enable effective
deployment and routine adoption of the
tools technologies and methods that are
being developed by the priority setting
trait discovery genomics and phenomics
areas of inquiry
our primary focus in the breeding
informatics area of inquiry is to work
with our partners to drive them towards
a data-driven breeding approach
this means implementing capabilities to
generate accurate predictions of
performance for advancement and
recycling decisions early in the
breeding pipeline as early as possible
we also work with our partners
to do simulations
to identify ways to leverage the tools
technologies and methodologies and
capacities that are being developed as
part of the ilc project to optimize
their breeding pipelines and maximize
performance in terms of varieties being
delivered to
farmers that meet their needs
to do this we're focusing really on
three core areas data digitization
analytics and the implementation of
continual improvement processes
while there are many definitions and
formal implementations of continual
improvement processes
within the breeding informatics area of
inquiry our focus is really just on the
core idea of continue improvement which
is the incremental improvement of a
process over time in many ways plant
breeding represents a continual
improvement process where we're trying
to make incremental increases in genetic
gain over time
so why the focus on continual
improvement well one because making a
series of very large and disruptive
changes to a breeding program decreases
probability of successful implementation
you can also put a very heavy strain on
programs
with limited or restricted capacity to
be able to make those types of changes
simultaneously
the second is that research and
innovation are not static we're
constantly developing new technologies
new methods new tools which in turn will
affect our breeding strategy as we try
and determine how to
leverage new tools and technologies to
maximize the efficiency of a breeding
program
also changes environmental conditions
changes in market conditions can lead to
different breeding objectives different
breeding focuses which in turn are going
to impact what types of enabling
capabilities need to be in place for a
breeding program
and this really represents an iterative
cycle that needs to be repeated
consistently year over year within a
breeding program so within the breeding
informatics aoi what we want to do is be
able to provide a lot of the the
software and analytical infrastructure
to enable programs to collect the types
of information
uh to have the systems in place to be
able to implement and effectively
implement a continuous or continual
improvement process within their
breeding program
the starting point for any engagement
with the breeding program is to first
really understand
what their current breeding strategy is
and what their current breeding
processes are now this could be a fairly
time consuming effort it revolves it
involves a lot of back and forth uh
between ill see
and breeders within the breeding
programs that we're working with but the
idea here is to try and document with as
much detail as possible exactly how
varieties are developed how they're
tested
how breeding objectives are being
defined what the focuses of a breeding
program are
this gives us a nice baseline to really
understand what the current state is
because that's really critical if we're
going to implement
improvement of a breeding strategy or
improvement of a breeding process we
first have to understand what the
current process is and for this we are
leveraging really some excellent tools
that were developed by the excellence in
breeding
platform
in particular we we use the excellence
in breeding pipeline manager
to work with reading programs to
identify really in detail what the
different steps of a program are
once we have a clear understanding of
what the current state of a breeding
program is what the current approaches
and strategies are
we then work with the program to start
to develop
simulation code to be able to develop
really an in silico version of the
breeding program
and to do this we leverage the alpha sim
r code
and we work with breeders to identify
various scenarios
we conduct analysis on historical data
to estimate parameters
and then we can work and go iteratively
back and forth where
we look at a scenario we test it we can
compare it to the current state we have
an iterative back and forth with the
breeders to identify ways in which we
might want to tweak a scenario
once we identify
different approaches to optimizing a
program that seem to have
high impact we can then move more onto a
consulting phase of the interaction and
breeding strategy where we're going to
work with our partners in the breeding
program to develop proof of concepts to
try and validate some of the findings
and also provide recommendations to the
programs on how they might go about
implementing some of these changes in
their breeding program and how we might
be able to track and monitor
the impact of these changes within a
program
one of the common scenarios that
breeding programs are interested in is
the implementation of genomic selection
and while in theory genomic selection
is often a far superior approach to
traditional breeding methodologies
it's also very complicated to implement
at scale in an effective way and
oftentimes programs don't necessarily
have a good idea of
where a good starting point is for the
implementation of genomic selection
in the breeding informatics area of
inquiry what we recommend is to take a
phased approach to the implementation of
genomic selection in the first phase
which we call informatics we're really
focused on implementing a lot of the
foundational capabilities that you need
to have in place to be able to
effectively utilize genomic selection
this is things like informatics
genotyping platforms imputation
platforms standard operating procedures
we recommend implementing genetic
quality control and pedigree
verification as a first step
and then
starting to do routine genotyping of all
material that goes into the pipeline now
a key element of genomic selection is
this ability to constantly refresh your
training set by routinely genotyping
everything that goes into a yield trial
we also work with programs to look at
you know what are some cost-effective
experimental designs that can enable
them to start routinely genotyping once
these foundational capabilities are in
place
we recommend moving on to optimization
of the actual variety testing a variety
development pipeline this would be
things like reducing time to
multi-environmental trials reducing the
number of years tested recycling earlier
within the vdp
once that's really in place and programs
are very comfortable with the idea of
genomic selection and they've validated
the value of implementing genomic
selection within their program
we start to work with programs to move
towards rapid cycling approaches which
in theory are the best but often in
practice some of the most difficult
approaches to work with when it comes to
the programs that we're working with
within the innovation lab for crop
improvement many of these programs
really are in phase one which is getting
in place the types of foundational
capabilities you need to implement
genomic selection and that's really
oftentimes our initial focus and our
engagement with our partners
our efforts to deploy enabling or
foundational
capabilities in technology really starts
with us
having a discussion with the eoc
partners to identify what are really the
key use cases and gaps
that are in place right now that need to
be addressed in order to move towards
more of a data-driven
approach to breeding
once we've had those conversations we
move towards deployment of appropriate
software systems
from there we identify functionality
gaps and deploy software systems and
finally our developers work across
multiple projects and with our partners
to write the types of software that's
needed to bridge these gaps and extend
functionality within the breeding
informatics
area of inquiry we really don't have the
capacity to build the types of large
software systems that need to be at the
core of any modern breeding program
thankfully many of these systems have
already been developed and so a lot of
our initial focus is just working with
the program to identify what the right
existing software solutions are and so
here on the slide i have some examples
of some of the major software systems
that are out there and that are in
common use within public sector breeding
programs and we can generally sort of
divide these up into systems that
support core breeding this would be bms
developed by ivp
breed base which is developed out of the
boyce thompson institute and the
enterprise breeding system that's being
developed by the cgir
in the genomics area there are two
major open source software systems that
are being widely adopted one is the gobi
project
negobi genomic data management system
and gig wall
finally you know field data collection
is a really important aspect of data
digitization we want to be able to have
data
flowing right from collection all the
way through to final results of analysis
without having a lot of manual steps
because that introduces or has the
potential to introduce errors and also
makes things much more complicated for
the breeders and so on the field data
collection side we work very closely
with pheno apps
and the effort in pino apps is really
being led by the phenomx area of inquiry
within ilse it should be noted that not
all of these systems can be so cleanly
defined into these broad categories
for instance breed based does have
genomic capabilities enterprise breeding
system
when complete will be deployed with the
gobi system on the back end handling the
genomic needs
where we come in with uh the breeding
informatics area of inquiry is the fact
that
for a lot of the types of use cases that
these programs need support for really
none of these systems individually can
fully support
and so there has to be a lot of work
to really
develop the piping between systems
to be able to fully support a workflow
from start to finish genomic selection
being a prime example of this you need
genomic data you need phenotypic data
as well as the analytics to be able to
effectively implement genomic selection
and while this has been widely
recognized as a really critical gap in
terms of what's available out there in
software for breeding programs it's been
traditionally very difficult
to address because these projects
the way in which they're organized
often makes it difficult to to really
you know develop the kind of
software that bridges these gaps between
systems and so
this is a gap that we recognize when
developing the project and we're fully
committed to being
really
focused on this aspect of providing
software solutions and new tools and
methodologies to our partners within
the elc project
within the elc project we try and be
agnostic in terms of what types of
software we work with our partners to
deploy and adopt that said we do have
some criteria that determines whether or
not we're willing to work with a certain
software project or a certain piece of
breeding software
first the software needs to be well
supported it needs to be well documented
and there need to be some accessible
resources for training and adoption the
second is the software needs to either
be broccoli compliant or committed to
working with us to implement broppy
for those that are not familiar with
broppy bropi stands for the breeding
application programming interface
broppy has defined has defined a
standardized
set of data model structures
that communicate the basic information
of plant breeding
it's a technical specification which
software developers can turn into code
which communicates using the standard
and the advantage of having these
standards in place is that when we're
trying to build functionality that
connects across multiple pieces of
software multiple software systems is we
can build it once and then it is easily
adaptable to different types of
configurations of software that any
given program might be deploying within
their breeding program
currently broppy provides specifications
for core breeding
for germplasm
for phenotyping and for genotyping
these represent
the types of capabilities that you need
to be able to support a large number of
breeding use cases but there are still
some gaps both in the phenomics space as
well as the analytics space and so
within elsi we're actively working with
the broppy project
to implement standards in some of these
additional domains to fully support
the types of workflows and the types of
use cases that we're trying to support
as part of the illc project
in terms of closing the gaps
what we really want to implement
as mentioned earlier is a fully
digitized
system in which
from the point of collection in the
field all the way through to results
that can be used to make decisions
either advancement recycling decisions
about potential changes to breeding
processes is completely digital
and completely supports the types of
work processes and breeding processes
that are being implemented within a
breeding program
we start by deploying existing systems
in this example we're looking at phenol
apps bms and gobi but we could easily
replace these
particular software systems with other
broppy compliance software and this type
of workflow would work the same
any breeding program that has deployed
these systems will quickly realize that
there are lots of gaps that are present
in terms of being able to fully support
modern breeding processes from end to
end from collection all the way to
decision support and so the software
developers within lc are primarily
focused on identifying these gaps
bropi to be able to map across systems
and then to build the type of code to
fill in these gaps and really provide
the types of end-to-end support you need
to fully optimize a breeding program and
to effectively implement continual
improvement processes
you know so what are we doing so we're
working on
building systems that that connect
between the various pieces of software
pheno apps is being deployed as part of
llc
it falls under the phenomx area of
inquiry but there's a long history of
phenoapps working with a lot of these
software systems and working with the
property community to implement these
types of connections that's not
necessarily the case for other pieces of
software for instance bms is a great
piece of breeding software but does not
provide the types of adequate support
needed for any type of genomic enabled
breeding process gobi on the other hand
is a fantastic software system for
managing genomic information for
implementing genomic specific breeding
processes but does not really have the
capabilities to manage core breeding
processes and so one effort that we're
really focused on right now is being
able to map broppy endpoints between the
bms and gobi system to enable these
types of uk use cases in a breeding
program another common gap is just being
able to run state-of-the-art analytics
that are needed to make the best
possible breeding decisions right now it
often times involves
you know pulling out excel files running
various types of software
to be able to effectively do this to
some extent you have to be a
biometrician or a quantitative
geneticist and have some coding
abilities so we're partnering with the
excellence in breeding project to build
you know a proper analytics engine that
can work directly with these systems to
enable breeders to be able to submit
requests for analyses have those run and
then have those results presented to
them in a way that makes it easy or
easier to make quality decisions about
the breeding program about advancement
decisions and about recycling
so where are we at currently with
the breeding informatics area of inquiry
well we have ongoing work with our
partner or our center of innovation in
west africa to document breeding
pipelines and identify simulation
scenarios and implement simulation code
we're focusing primarily on this coi on
the breeding strategy piece because they
are fairly advanced in terms of
deployment of breeding software
so they've already deployed bms to
manage their core breeding processes and
they're in the process of deploying
gigwa to manage their genomic
information
for our cois in west africa
they're really at the start of the
journey in terms of being able to
digitize their data and so we've been
working very closely with bms as a
partner
we've deployed the bms system and we've
completed training on the bms system
as mentioned we're currently mapping
broppy endpoints between genomic
management systems both gobi and digwa
and we have
initiated software development to begin
to start supporting genomic breeding use
cases
many of these programs aren't routinely
using genomic information yet but it is
on the horizon and we want to make sure
that these capabilities are in place
when they start doing routine genotyping
and finally significant progress has
been made in the development of
germplasm evaluation tools and this is
being done in collaboration with the
excellence in breeding we hope to see
the first release of this piece of
software
towards the end of the summer early fall
and we'll be continuing to enhance those
capabilities moving
forward with that i would just like to
thank everyone again for being here
and thanks again for the opportunity to
speak i look forward to the interactive
q a session
to be able to address any questions you
may have